With the return of Deadpool's Wade Wilson
comes a whole new set of faces that will join
the hero in his fight against evil in Deadpool
2 and a new standout has taken the Internet
by storm.
Meet Peter, played by Rob Delaney.
On the surface, Peter is your average middleaged
dude.
But it seems that what he lacks in super powers,
he makes up for with enthusiasm.
Rob Delaney may be a new face in the comic
book movies, but this isn't his first rodeo.
Let's take a closer look at why Peter from
Deadpool 2 looks so darn familiar.
"You're in."
Funniest Person on Twitter
Back before Twitter expanded its character
limit from 140 to 280, Delaney regularly used
the social media platform to workshop material,
bringing witty quips and humorous observations
to the Internet before it was the fashionable
thing to do.
In 2012, Delaney became the first person to
be named "The Funniest Person on Twitter"
at Comedy Central's Comedy Awards.
Delaney explained his social media success
to Mashable, saying,
"Don't work too hard on a tweet.
[...] When you see people trying to, for example,
synthesize two current news stories into one
'clever' tweet, it can get pretty clunky and
their labor is obvious, rendering their tweet
unfunny."
Published author
In 2013, Delaney released a memoir titled,
Rob Delaney: Mother.
Wife.
Sister.
Human.
Warrior.
Falcon.
Yardstick.
Turban.
Cabbage.
While the book featured its fair share of
dad humor and fart jokes, Delaney also used
the medium to explore his very real struggles
with depression and alcohol addiction.
A decade before he honed his craft online,
he was regularly bombing on stage, and he
made a habit of getting blackoutdrunk.
With his book, Delaney returns to the rock
bottom moments that helped shape the man he's
become.
Delaney told The L.A. Times,
"[It] was a memoir that paid no attention
to chronology and was just about memories
that surfaced in my own, sort of, psyche.
Because I figured those would be the ones
that would be most interesting to people."
"Yeah, I drove into a building in LA, uhhuh.
And broke both my arms and was in jail, in
a wheelchair."
Standup
According to an interview with Good Men Project,
Delaney's life changed in 2009 after he was
arrested for driving under the influence.
He got sober, and about a year later, he began
seriously pursuing standup comedy.
The comedian explained,
"Honesty is the main ingredient.
I mean, you must be funny, but certainly the
funniest stuff will always be the most honest.
No secret there."
Delaney has since played shows all over the
country, and eventually landed his own 2013
comedy special Rob Delaney: Live at the Bowery
Ballroom.
"Now, if you see someone with a neck tattoo,
you know that they got it at their local muffin
shop.
They got like a frappuccino neck tattoo special."
TV roles
Over the years, Delaney has continued racking
up credits both behind and in front of the
camera.
For a short time, he had a project in the
works at Comedy Central called "At Rob Delaney,"
which unfortunately never saw the light of
day.
As he continued flexing his comedic muscles,
Delaney found himself graduating from the
confines of the Internet and eventually landing
in the posh arena of primetime network television,
appearing in shows like Cougar Town and Burning
Love.
The funnyman also appeared in multiple sketches
on Comedy Central's Key & Peele, with his
standout performance being the Campaign Advisor
character.
Catastrophe
In 2014, Delaney relocated his family to the
UK.
"I love it, I love living there, and their
teeth are… a mess."
According to the Los Angeles Times, just one
year after settling into his new home, the
hit series Catastrophe premiered on Britain's
Channel 4 and, soon after, Amazon Prime's
streaming platform.
The Emmynominated, BAFTAwinning series is
cocreated and cowritten by Delaney and Sharon
Horgan.
"Thank you Sharon Horgan for teaching me how
to write comedy.
I could do standup, I could tell a joke but
not make a show, thank you!"
Not only did the series disrupt the romcom
formula with a pleasant amount of vulgarity
throughout the realistic subject matter came
at audiences with a brutal sense of honesty
seldom seen on the small screen.
Variety reported back in 2016 that the streaming
service renewed Catastrophe through its fourth
season.
UK star
One of the perks of being the Funniest Person
on Twitter is the global audience that the
platform provides.
Once Delaney relocated to Britain, his star
only continued to rise.
In between his time as a fulltime comedian,
TV star, and writer, Delaney has made a habit
of appearing on a handful of British panel
shows, a popular type of game show that throws
celebrities into the mix.
Throughout his experience doing standup comedy
and pontificating on pop culture online, Delaney
has proven himself to be a worthy competitor.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!